UFOs are real. We have proof. The United States
military has been studying them. There's one case
in particular that I can't stop thinking about.
It's this case from November 2004 off the coast
of California. The military report from the
day tells a story of this blue sky “unlimited
visibility” day. Of an aircraft carrier that
detects “multiple anomalous aerial vehicles”
descending “very rapidly” from 60,000 feet down
to 50 feet in a matter of seconds. These flying
things just hover, they “stay stationary on the
radar for a short time, and then they depart at
high velocities and turn rates.” So they sent
out these pilots to go chase these things down
and see what was going on. And they actually
got video of this stuff. The report describes
it as “an elongated Tic Tac shape about 47 feet
in length, solid white, smooth with no edges or
wings.” As a journalist, I am incredibly skeptical
of all things paranormal. Okay? Do we have proof
that there are extraterrestrials visiting
our world? No. But what we do know is that